le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
être son propre patron et créer son
entreprise c'est le rêve de beaucoup de
jeunes pour les aider à se lancer et
pérenniser leur activité
le département vient de créer le
tremplin pour l'activité des jeunes
le taz propose aux créateurs
d'entreprise un accompagnement et un
suivi et une aide allant jusqu'à 8000
euros stéphanie vient d'ouvrir son salon
de coiffure à saint-denis
elle a fait appel otage pour démarrer
son activité
vous faites pas trop chez nous pas de
cours voilà maintenant un mois que
stéphanie s'est installé dans ce salon
un salon qu'elle gère seul après des
études dans la coiffure et l'obtention
d'un brevet de maîtrise
la jeune femme vise l'indépendance
professionnelle j'ai juste à rendre des
comptes à maman j'ai personnes au dessus
je fais les choix que je veux je veux je
des besoins je fais ce que je veux en
venir
stéphanie repère alors un local et
décide de foncer journée pas laisser
passer cette chance là sur mon nez du
coup bon ben j'ai souhaité me feront
perso parallèlement elle monte un
dossier pour bénéficier du tremplin pour
l'activité des jeunes
ce nouveau dispositif départemental
visant à encourager la création
d'entreprises dans un contexte
économique et social difficile
on parle toujours de levier pour les
insérer vraiment dans l'action
économique et social de la réunion
ces jeunes pourront s'initier commencé
notre pays accéder à cette subvention de
8000 euros 1000 euros maximum qu'on
donne donc sur cette durée de 1 an
d'abord 70% au départ et puis 30% par la
suite
l'aide financière du taz est attribuée
aux jeunes de 20 à 30 ans sans condition
de ressources particulières des critères
idéal pour la situation de stéphanie
pourquoi l'otage parce que c'est celui
qui pourrait fonder le mieux à mes
critères donc mon âge
le fait que bon bah j'étais jeune je
touche pas le rsa tout simplement
donc je ne pouvais pas cumuler plusieurs
subventions et puis celle là était la
plus complète dans sont souvent elle va
jusqu'à ces nouveaux quoi je voulais
faire avec ou sans cette subvention
je ne pourrais pas donc changé lancer
dans un débat est raisonnable et puis
bon ben rambo c'est un petit peu quand
même mais au delà d'une enveloppe
financière
le dispositif prévoit également un
accompagnement des créateurs via le
réseau point chance qui regroupe
plusieurs organismes partenaires au
départ
si le jeune n'est pas du tout aux
initiés il pourra se servir du réseau
penchant surtout de la couveuse qui
permet de porter autant sur le plan
juridique et sur le plan administratif
le projet pour s'asseoir viable en
parallèle à ça il ya aussi les autres
poissons son métier pratiques de gestion
à des adieux et bien d'offres et nous
allons faire un suivi d'au moins trois
ans pour pouvoir être présent dans les
difficultés de ces jeunes dans quelques
jours
stéphanie a d'ailleurs une entrevue avec
sa conseillère pour préparer sa première
embauche
elle voudrait engager une prothésiste
ongulaire pour répondre aux besoins de
sa clientèle
elle a même trouvé la candidate idéale
sa soeur emanuela je suis demandeur
d'emploi depuis plus de 6 l'an d'ici la
semaine prochaine on devrait voir une
conseillère fort conseillé stéphanie sur
le contre adapté à mon âge à moi et
selon ma profession aussi et ensuite tu
vas avoir qu'est ce qui est plus
avantageux pour son entreprise qui
viennent des bars et de la motivation
des compétences est désormais un soutien
professionnel et financier
avec ces dispositifs d'insertion le
département veut accompagner chaque
demandeur d'emploi quel que soit son
profil
quand vous retournez vers le département
qui est quand même le chef de file de
l'assertion ya deux problématiques avoir
en premier
d'abord la problématique sociale si vous
êtes mal d'entre eux
vous avez des problèmes de santé c'est
avec des problèmes de budget les équipes
sont là vous accompagne pour régulariser
ce problème après chez les jeunes aussi
souvent leur demande une expérience de
france professionnel avoir au départ un
parcours d'insertion bianne ou ied et ça
donne l'expérience le tremplin qu'il
faut pour aller plus loin la personne en
recherche d'emploi de devant la chorale
y installer son ope parfois c'est c'la
de vivre à ce n'est pas le dire vous
avez tel dispositif est rentré dedans
c'est là nous devons accompagner la
personne à avoir sont parfois de a
jusqu'à z le tremplin pour l'activité
des jeunes s'adressent aux personnes de
20 à 30 ans à la recherche d'une
insertion professionnelle souhaitant se
lancer dans l'entrepreneuriat il propose
un accompagnement et un suivi du projet
via le réseau point chance ainsi qu'une
subvention allant jusqu'à 8000 euros
sans conditions de ressources
pour plus de renseignements sur le tage
un numéro vert est mis à votre
disposition au 0 800 1 801 000
vous pouvez aussi vous rendre sur le
site du département au www.sears.ca 4
point fr
m